تعب سنين طويله انفق في بناء هذا البيت
وفي ثوان مزلزله خلخله اساساته
اب وام وابناء واحفاد بات مصيرهم التشرد
لا يجرؤون على دخول منزلهم ومن بعيد
يراقبونه
كانت
بالجنه
وراح البيت وراحوا المصاري ما بقى
عايشين بيجيبوا من برا اللي بيجيب شغله
بيعطينا خبز بيضه
يعني اي شيء في معايير انطاكيا ما بعد
الزلزال تعد هذه الاسره محظوظه نجى جميع
افرادها الا من كسر في ذراع هذا الفتاه
كان اخر الهاربين وانهار جزء من درج البيت
على ذرائه
في مركز مدينه انطاكيا يتكشف حجم الكارثه
لا تكاد ترى بنايه سالمه بشكل كامل هنا
ترك الزلزال اثره في كل مكان
فتحت البنايات المهدمه تتحطم امال اقارب
العالقين في نجاتهم كلما مر الوقت
تتكثف مساعي فرق الانقاذ مع وصول المعدات
الى المدينه النائيه لكن عدد البنايات
المتضرره كبير وعدد فرق البحث والتنقيب
محدود ولا سبيل الى تلبيه كل نداءات
الاستغاثه
من بين هؤلاء المستغيثين مروان ترك في هذا
البيت زوجه وطفله في عامها الثالث
اذا حدا عم يسمعني يرد
لم يفقد الامل بعد في نجاتهم وينتظر ان
يصل دوره لتبدا عمليه رفع الانقاض
يستبد به الحنين والاحساس بالعجز امام
واقع المرير الا اجي هون ثلاثه ايام
واحد لكن اطلع من الالبوم تحت
الوعود او
[موسيقى]
البنايات التي تهدمت بسبب زلزال في تركيا
توجد هنا في ولايه هاتاي بعد مرور ايام
على الواقع تعيش المدينه بلا كهرباء ولا
خدمات هاتف وحاله اختناق مروري تصاعب وصول
سياره الاسعاف في الوقت المناسب
ووسط كل هذا تتواتر قصص نجاه ملهمه لاهالي
العالقين فبعد مرور 84 ساعه يخرج هذا
الطفل من بين الركام بجهود المسعفين كما
هي الا دقائق حتى اخرج فرق الانقاذ احد
اقاربه
خلف كل قطعه ركام هنا طفوله واحلام
وذكريات وسعي لعيش افضل بعد زلزال تغيرت
الاولويات وبدانا بالبحث عن احبتهم وكلهم
امل في ايجادهم واسعافهم وابقائهم على قيد
الحياه اما الاخرون فصارت الاولويات
متغيره البحث عن ماوى وعن الغذاء وعن
الماء صار اولويه ملحه اما الكهرباء
والانترنت فصارت طرفا لا تملكه الا قله
ابن الجزيره
انطاكيا